I don't want you to think much about
this I want you to straight like the
first word comes up for each of these
associated with it but what's the first
thing that comes to mind I said reason
and then what's the first thing that
comes to mind when I say state and you
can draw on your experience you can do
anything in life with
same thing with philosophy or religion
and then Abraham will give you a minute
to to sketch that out I'll tell you
about this guy character so we're
finishing up the semester nowhere near
contemporary philosophy nowhere near
where philosophy is today but you know
having covered a lot of ground from the
ancient Greeks through some of the
medievals through some of the moderns
and now we're reaching the later part of
the mountain period with this guy sir
and Kierkegaard here's all the things
that's because we Danish and that's a
letter that we only have in our English
orthography I think it's pronounced
Buddha so sooner in Kierkegaard the game
was called character and he was a Danish
[ __ ] like I said who is writing in the
first part of the 19th century so not
that long ago and he's responding to a
lot of the people that we've studied
this semester biggest person that he's
responding to we didn't study that's
that's Hegel and the reason we didn't
study Hegel is because Cagle is
notoriously difficult and takes a lot
time to learn about because everything
is connected to everything else yeah but
he did respond to cops and he does talk
about Descartes and he also talks about
Socrates and in some ways what you can
think of Kierkegaard is doing is
responding as a religious thinker he is
he's a very clearly religious thinker to
what's going on in the intellectual
culture and ordinary culture of his day
and one of the terms that you don't see
coming up in this book but which does
come up in many of the other books that
Evo is it squirming and you know when
you're in your history classes you got
to remember that that's I remember
coming out I get in world history
or probably did have medieval history
when you talk about Christendom you mean
the countries or the cultures in which
Christianity plays an important role and
that's changed over time has this right
where did where did Christianity start
out pretty humble beginnings a bunch of
Jewish fisherman you know this carpenter
guy tax Condor and well they have some
Greek people following them around some
Romans also Jewish people in furs and
then some some Samaritans which
lettuce spreads out right you guys all
know the history of the spread of
Christianity girls start spreading
through the Roman Empire and even go
outside of the bowels of the Roman
Empire yeah Christianity becomes the
major intellectual and religious force
for over thousand years and then you
guys remember you know story about the
Protestant Reformation you know there's
one big monolithic church and it breaks
up into other churches right right
Luther the 95 theses and John Calvin and
probably remember maps right where
here's the Lutheran area and here's the
Calvinist area and here's the the
Anglican area well they all had a lot of
things still in common Denmark was a
Lutheran country and Christianity as far
as Kierkegaard thought it'd become kind
of tepid when when a religion any
religion becomes the dominant way of
looking at things there's a lot of
people who you know give lip service to
the religion but are they are they
really committed to it are they really
practicing it and they're really
studying I mean what's what's your
experience of that sort of stuff the
United States is nominally a Christian
nation culturally not politically
culturally does everybody who you know
claims to be a Christian are they all on
fire and you know I'm doing exactly what
you'd expect a person to do what's your
experience yeah he sort of depends I
mean I think some people follow it more
closer than others
yeah it depends very much and so you
know just being within the society or
being within the state doesn't
necessarily mean that you have any sort
of commitments
you could you know you could wake it up
every Sunday morning and go to church
like you're supposed to and it's kind of
mumble along and never really think much
about it Monday didn't make much sense
and a sermon why did it make much x well
you're not connecting it to anything
else right if that's what you're doing
that's just sort of a thing you do
there's a lot of people who live like
that and there were a lot of people who
live like that and you can kick against
time but back then it was you know was
kind of important that you actually be a
member and this is before you know World
War one in World War 2 and the Holocaust
and all these sort of things that kind
of shook people's faith in progress and
the idea was you know Europe was the
center of the world and they made all
this progress and Christianity seemed to
be kind of at the center of that and as
you know so it looked like everything
was just getting better and better and
better and all you had to do was sort of
you know follow along and you could be
part of that and what most about this
notion of Chris and Diana and he saw
this as a passionate commitment to
something that was absurd and that's
that's kind of an interesting thing to
say do people who you know would like
you to be Christians do they usually
stress to you this is absurd this
doesn't make sense I mean you may feel
that way if they're trying to convince
you that maybe a reason why you'd reject
it do they usually make that as a plea
for why you should believe it why not
isn't it fun sometimes to believe in
absurd things we like to watch kind of
absurd TV shows pretty soon do you guys
like to watch those claymation Rudolph
Santa
Krusty Pathan's Wells pure absurdity
right
reindeers that talk and their noses
light up and they fly in the air and
they go to the land of misfit toys all
that sort of stuff
isn't that crazy you don't take it
seriously though aaah okay that's it
that's it good
that's an important distinction it's
there for fun religious conviction we
don't usually see as being done just for
fun though I think some people do it
just for fun you know sort of try it out
now there's there's a actually a long
history of some Christian thinkers
stressing the absurdity of appreciator
folium said I believe because of some
sir and so he's taken as being sort of
at an extreme most of the people that
are Christians they don't take that line
right did they in some come out and say
God's existence can't prove it totally
absurd just gotta have faith wouldn't be
doing this class with the ant song what
do you remember about it
what's what what's the thing that you
associate with them that you're
concerned with being yeah what what did
you do for philosophy
hope you guys remember this a week from
now you know an argument about God's
existence Thomas Aquinas we looked at
him for the same sort of thing did those
guys say can't prove that sort of stuff
it's absurd gotta believe it you should
have a passionate commitment to him not
based on anything rational and some said
the opposite of that you know even if
you don't believe it
here's why you ought to believe that
here's the argument for it I'm going to
use some reason to explain the Christian
or least certain parts of the Christian
faith
so cute regard to sticking out a very
different position that doesn't mean
that he's not using reason at all or
he's not doing philosophy yes but he's
doing it in a way that's very unlike
most of the other philosophers that we
studied he's telling you some stories
and then even he's analyzing these these
stories he's trying to connect it up
with you or the book that we're looking
at is fear and trembling so anyone who
literally wouldn't recall where this
phrase comes from comes from Scripture
comes from st. Paul st. Paul so that
everybody has to work out their own
salvation in fear and trembling and it
was kind of about not being a busybody
being so concerned everybody else
being saved look at your own salvation
and that started you know lecturing
other people about that and you do it
not being completely assured but in fear
and trembling right you take this stuff
seriously you think that there really is
the kind of God that Christians talk
about or Jews or Muslims for that matter
and you think that he's got this awesome
majesty and is infinite beyond anything
that we could conceive of even if we
can't know something right camera hit or
you know it's a Trinity the three nuts
or whatever that is if you think that's
very seriously you should actually have
kind of an emotional response to that
realizing you know not just how powerful
your reason is but perhaps how weak it
is how often we go astray and how easy
it is for us to screw things up now this
is know these are religious people who
are saying this these are these are not
just they're saying about themselves
we're saying I have to work out my own
salvation in fear and trembling because
even though you know I've been writing
these letters Paul I'm a screw-up
what about this guy Abraham what did you
guys write down when I ask you to do
that sort of word association what what
came to mind
you might say I'm kind of curious okay
yeah I mean we renamed people with a lot
of biblical names we used to my family I
still do side of Eli and Jacob all these
were things as cousins today when
Abraham Lincoln okay the Bible we learn
about Abraham in the Bible in the first
look at it right which is called Genesis
and Genesis means beginnings origin god
yeah okay cuz in the Bible God has
talked about his being the God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob and Isaac is
going to be important part of the story
too so this guy Abraham he's a he's a
Mesopotamian at that time there are two
main cultural centers in the Western
world or Egypt this old civilization and
then Mesopotamia these are both River
civilizations they developed a high
level of complexity and have their own
complex religions and a very urban way
of life compared to pretty much
everything else was you know either in
the forests and hunting or are they were
doing some subsistence farming were they
were herding sheep
and you know imagine that imagine
leaving the existence that you're used
to getting rid of almost all the the
technology that you have been doing
somewhere else and starting a new life
and now the life that you would have
like staked out for yourself like oh so
great God comes to Abraham he says all
right leave leave the city leave your
family leave all these things that you
know head up into the desert into the
the wasteland like a nomad because I'm
going to do some great things for you
and Abraham obeys the actually goes
along
they might so people were really
gullible back that we don't know story
because well we ever these like you know
short verses write an entire lifetimes
compressed entities these verses well we
do know is that Abraham leaves and God
makes a promise to me says two things it
says I'm gonna make you the father of
many nations what does that mean he's
gonna have a lot of kids most kids are
gonna have a lot of kids and they're
going to and you can think of it a
spiritual way or in a physical way but
that's one thing and then the other
thing is I'm going to give you some land
that's that's what you know Jews Israel
that's that's the promised land right
because Abraham is seen as being a
father of Judaism so he goes and he
wanders around he's got this wife Sarah
I'm gonna have some adventures and I'm
they get old I think I mean if he if you
think that that Bible stories are boring
read the Bible sometime Sarah and
Abraham go to Egypt and he pretends that
that she's his sister so that the
Pharaoh who's got a thing for the ladies
won't kill him and take her and then you
know God strikes the Pharaoh with a
curse and the Pharaohs ticked off now
and says you know what are you doing to
me I treated you good and then you lied
to me about your own wife this is the
sort of stuff that goes on in these
stories so he does have some adventures
but what's really
about this Sara can't have children so
what happens then to this whole you're
gonna be the father of many nations
business any of you remember the how the
story goes at that point
Sara does something kind of tricky least
we would see it that way most go maybe
something kind of loving she says well I
can't even kids but my maid can yeah
yeah and that's that's it they're his
first son Ishmael who was once believed
is the rightful inheritor and then God
comes and tells Sarah I'm going to give
you a son and she laughs you'll ask that
guy again these these old stories are
great because they're very human that's
not this you know you know I'm gonna do
everything you say
these people are you know interacting
with God in funny ways she laughs I got
and God says now I'm gonna hear you have
a son
yeah sure enough a year later she does
Isaac yeah and by this time they're
pretty old now here's where we get to
the part of the story that that really
concerns us
what does Abraham have to do with eyes
he raises them as his son
Ezio ought to eventually yes the Dryad
Ishmael away which Abraham didn't seem
to be too happy about Sarah was you know
worried that Ishmael were trying to
steal
Isaac's birthright what so now he's down
to one son what does God tell Abraham to
do we've got one son so sacrificing
sacrifice meant then killing you know he
said back then what a sacrifice was
generally she took a goat or a lamb and
put it on an altar and it was bound and
you slit his throat blood offerings and
then he burned it up burnt offering and
God tells Abraham this so after all that
wandering after all that time all that
trusting in God and God coming through
he's got a son by his wife who he loves
very dearly
now God tells him something that sounds
totally crazy you have to sacrifice your
son to me this is what I require it and
that's what Kierkegaard is is trying to
think of with Abraham being a sort of
picker sort of pipe Abraham has faith
when I when I had you do the thing for
faith what what sort of associations did
you have what does faith make you think
of yeah pair okay a prayer prayer is
something that people that they
typically do what else do you guys write
down
I'm is NATO what did you rate God
alright the faith in hopefully it's not
yeah how many book out Wow more more
than half of the class so actually okay
that makes sense because we're used to
thinking of those things together is
faith something that you just haven't
got where is faith something that you
have to work at how do we often treat it
in our time I'm also in character itself
we don't kinda like a star player right
some people have faith some people don't
have to some people believe we have them
use faith as a synonym for belief some
people believe in God some people oh
right what probably determines whether
you believe in
I'm guessing you probably haven't given
a ton of thought to it yeah you'll
probably give it more to it later what
do you think probably the number one
thing we could look at decrepit to
figure out who believes in God you've
got that belief from wasn't yet born
yeah probably from your parents your
parents believed in God mr. Church
probably believed in God go to church
well no college is having most kids your
parents didn't believe in God they if
they said oh that's a bunch of BS or
something then you probably don't
believe either and that may change over
time you may have come from a religious
household and then say yeah this isn't
for me or you may come for me your
religious household and say oh I wish I
would have known about this right now I
believe those sort of things change
don't they and some of you may have
already gone through one change one way
or the other
well Kierkegaard is talking about faith
but he thinks that faith is something
difficult a lot of people begin with
faith and then they want to go on from
faith and I think you probably would see
an solver Descartes or people like that
in this way mostly oudy actually says he
says not merely in the realm of Commerce
but in the world of ideas as well as our
age is organizing a regular clearance
sale through how many of you went out
shopping on Black Friday then again for
Cyber Monday some of you have your
Christmas shopping probably taking care
of the rest of you you have some work to
do I guess
everything is to be had at such a
bargain it's questionable whether in the
end there's anybody who want to bid you
know when something is really cheap
people start saying what's wrong with
that don't they this is this broken this
must be fake because it's really really
cheap clearance now respectable to fight
price fixer who conscientiously directs
attention to the significant march of
modern philosophy this is not content
with doubting everything but goes
forever remember Descartes doubted
everything right perhaps it would be
untimely a nail time to guess them where
they're going but surely it's prettiest
amount of true self to regard it is
certainly everything since otherwise it
would be a query going further
the preliminary movement they they they
have therefore all of them made
presumably with such ease they did not
find it necessary to let drop a word
about the house for not even he who
anxiously and with deep concerns sought
a little enlightenment was able to find
any guiding sign they're so glad the
card did it we're going to start where
decart did and this was a very common
sort of view about philosophy we have to
read the ancient people and medieval
people we're going to start with
Descartes and you know hyperbolic down
and modern philosophy we're just going
to move on from there I hope that one of
the things that has come across to you
in this semester because we read Plato
and Aristotle and Anselm and Thomas
before we went to Descartes
is how much you would have missed if you
just started with Descartes I think that
some of you at least are going to come
away with from this class with an
interest in the sky Socrates and it's
going to last throughout your lifetime
about some of the things that he said
and did and they may not make sense to
you right away
but they may assume greater importance
later on and if they do you know why
that's the case it's because you did
some work see philosophy is in large
part do it work it's sitting down with
texts and thinking about what's going on
here and reading it and mulling it over
and seeing if it applies to your own
line and seeing if looking at your life
and that light changes your viewpoint on
things and then moving on to the next
thing that you do that like Kierkegaard
is saying everybody wants to start we
over here when we should be starting
over here not just you know taking for
granted that we've made this progress we
don't need to read this and it's the
same way for any any other thing you can
think of I think about all the commodity
items how many do you listen from time
to time to classical music anybody when
you hear it right you recognize it and
I'm not a good one to talk about this
actually because I there's only a few
classical composers who I actually get
much out of because I'm Kenneth
Philistine when it comes to us but I
have a friend who knows classical music
and said no I like talking with him
because I can ask him what's going on in
this piece and he can tell me and then
when I come away from a conversation
with them I not only know so much more I
feel so much more my life has become
richer you know why because they didn't
think that I knew at all and didn't need
to ask something about it and didn't
need to do some work and it's the same
way with your professions that you're
going to answer you know you're going to
be learning and studying a lot of a lot
of stuff and you already have some sort
of inclination towards it right at home
hey all right doing something that
tracks you don't go into something you
hate but if you allow yourself to be
open to it and begin from the beginning
point you're gonna learn so much and
you're gonna develop and you're gonna
grow well that's what Kierkegaard is
talking about he says what those ancient
Greece who had some understanding of
philosophy regarded as a task for a
whole lifetime with a veteran combatant
attained when he had preserve the
equilibrium of death through all the
pitfalls he encountered this is where
everybody begins at our time so that's
about philosophy it's the same kind of
thing he says in our time nobody is
content to stop with faith but wants to
go further it would perhaps be rash to
ask where these people are going and the
old days it was different for them asked
for a whole lifetime it's very easy to
begin by saying I believe in God I'm
alright with them
I you know in the track that I'm
supposed to be now it's all smooth
sailing from here on that's a very
superficial way of approaching religious
faith business whether it's you know
stick whatever religion you want that's
not the way that the founders of these
religions talked or lived and that's not
the way of the early generations of
people think about staying in song for
example he was a month right he went to
a monastery that meant that he gave up
all of all of his possessions they said
I'm gonna settle down with these monks
if you read his wife they don't like it
a lot of these months took him a long
time to win them over by treating them
lovingly when they treated him horrible
mean things that was work by doing that
kind of work he learned more and more
what this book that
I was about we often approach these
these kind of things as if you know the
meanings of things is right there on the
surface and you grasp them like that or
maybe we can get the cliffnotes what do
you guys do sparknotes right and what
else Wikipedia when you're engaged what
else do you turn to
there's no shame in saying it's okay
that's a good start
well sooner or later you actually want
to sell down and dig into things and
it's that way with with this term
religion wonderful stations come up with
that for you guys what is religion me
yeah God okay religion is usually tied
to some conception of God or something
what else
prayer is you know definitely involved
for most people whether they're Buddhist
Jewish Christian Hindu most everybody it
was involved in religion actually praise
God almost what did you count you bro
see okay that's kind of interesting
because if you look at every world
religion controversy was there from the
start let's take this Jesus guy for
example you hope that I don't offend
anybody by speaking kind of into
reverently but you know he actually
spoke kinda dirty reverently himself
didn t he walk around and mess with
people and tell them things that were
really hard for them to hear and every
once in a while they'd say kill that guy
and they they tried to do it a couple
times didn't they before they they and
they did it again I mean there's there's
one verse or set of verses I think it's
where a couple different sects are
trying to you know narrow him down on
something and they may ask him this
puzzling question and then he throws a
puzzle back at that and they realize
that you know this isn't going to work
that's what what are they gonna do let's
kill right that's controversy that gets
people's emotions involved their
passions involved
why would somebody commit themselves to
this sort of sort of thing though
well they put themselves they made
himself ah lowing him around
I mean imagine what that was like I got
this guy who's kind of unpredictable who
just until a couple years ago was a
carpenter and now he's making you know I
was telling about his parables and
stories and he seems to be smarter than
anybody else you've ever come across but
you have no idea what he's gonna do next
and he says leave your families in
saying this to people who are like you
know 40 50 years old
leave your counting table you know leave
that money that's been entrusted dated
and follow me leave your nets and your
boats and all that follow me around
here's your bag
here's your staff now I'm not going to
be with you right now
go out to those towns over there and
preach this message to them that you
just can't you know learn over the last
couple of weeks or months or whatever
and see how that goes
doesn't that sound crazy when you put it
like that when it's not even you know
the church with candles and incense and
all that sort of stuff doesn't sound
like a crazy story and yet these people
did it and they did it by you know not
just one or two but eventually thousands
well that's what we call
and yeah you know you desert you guys
are passionately committed to some
things right I think your family well
see you guys passionately committed to
where you would you would brave
controversy maybe even people beating
you off they're saying terrible things
about you or to you what would you what
would you what's worth that for you guys
is there anything hope there's something
because that's what gives your life
meaning the fact that you you have some
some attachments you're not you're not
just brains right
you're also hurts let's go on to this
this idea that night at seven
Kierkegaard calls a birdie they have
there's other nights of faith as well
home they can exist they could be in
this room right now
they could be walking down the street he
says you know you can't actually
recognize them along this time when
they're there but they're they're out
there this is what Abraham do he
believed that God with the whole time he
believed he believed God would not
require Isaac ISM it was willing
nevertheless to sacrifice him if it was
required so you know he's trusting and
in God that somehow this is all gonna
work out he doesn't have any idea how
it's going to happen
everything that that's been set up to
this point doesn't give him any sort of
clue but he is he's trusting he believes
by virtue of the absurd for there could
be no question of human calculation and
it was indeed the obtruded I work where
did of them should at the next instant
recall the requirement that's kind of
crazy isn't it if you your God should
you change your mind
seem kind of kind of silly but that's
what the Bible actually says that in
that and since God told them to do
something that seemed really out there
and then said well don't do that here's
the real RAM to sacrifice just testing
he says let us go further we let Isaac
really be sacrificed abraham believed he
did not believe that some day he would
be blessed in the beyond but then he
would be happy here in the world God
could give him a new Isaac could recall
the life of him who had been sacrificed
he believed by virtue of the absurd for
all human reckoning had long ceased to
function yeah what is contrasting
Abraham - is something different is what
sort of sacrifices two people have to
make in their lifetime but you can think
of your parents make any sacrifices then
you look up - yeah oh time should put
your time in certain things and not
others compromise yeah and you only get
so much and as you get older you realize
how little you get you know when you're
20 the whole lesson is that when you're
40 you start to get kind of miserly with
your time I guess when you're 60 it must
be really the next day so time yeah you
sacrifice time for things other people
who had to sacrifice say their dreams to
take care of somebody
or sometimes you have to sacrifice a
relationship we have to sacrifice
sometimes in order for things to be
better
well let me ask you this when you guys
have kids because most of you are gonna
have kids I think right kids what would
you be willing to sacrifice for them so
that they can be healthy happy
what do you think I mean everything she
once you have kids I can tell you this
from experience everything changes and
you see the world in a different way not
just a larger so have you got a kid you
know or anything like that but because
now you realize wow now I'm responsible
was responsible before when you know I
had a girlfriend
do not say your wife same thing but
you're responsible in a very different
way when you've a baby in your arms you
can't just like up and quit your job you
can't just like you know say oh I'm
gonna go off just put the kid in though
I'll be back you have to make a lot of
sacrifices you lose a lot of sleep a lot
of opportunities that you would have
taken in the past that's being resigned
to something and now nothing about when
you make a sacrifice there's some people
who talk about sacrifices going oh you
know I didn't really want to do it
anyway is that making a sacrifice no
let's take this event over here right
this this film screening if if you say
yeah I'm gonna go to that now that's
gonna mean I'm gonna have to miss dinner
there's probably the case right because
you're having a five o'clock class so
that's probably why that nobody's gonna
go right you rather go to have dinner
let's say you gave up dinner is it much
of a sacrifice if you if you had some
snack before you got to class or you're
not really hungry
there's more of a sacrifice if you're
hungry yeah there's more of a sacrifice
if you need something
good thing the night of infinite
resignation gives up something that's
good for some some greater good which
may not even be theirs he gives a lot of
examples of nights at the reservation
that can go that far
those are great things what he calls the
tragic hero the tragic hero the heroes
of tragedies they subordinate their own
desires their own wishes their own
fulfillment to some greater things
something bigger than that they pass
something up so you know you give some
examples from from his own time and
culture Socrates as an intellectual
tragic hero I remember when you read the
apology and the credo you could have
gotten out of town but he would have
been given something up in the process
you guys some of you you know wrote
about this that he would have been you
know transgressing what do you been
teaching me what do you what he taught
continued to lived in it but but
Socrates himself he died as a result
and even meant that he had to leave his
kids without a problem of course you
know his kids were but your age okay so
they Harbor really kids but he left his
wife without a husband all for the sake
of philosophy Agamemnon II - excellent
Agamemnon sacrifice somebody he
sacrificed something later so that the
Trojans let the Greek ships could go up
to the right and a fight in this this
great war
because Poseidon said that they couldn't
think about movies that you see where
somebody gives up a love so that
somebody else can be happy
have you ever seen a movie like that
they back off from their home needs
wants desires and they don't even say
anything about it
so that they don't they don't the other
person to feel bad and then you find out
in the end that they had you know made
this the sacrifice of their own
designers that's a tragic hero at least
what with character is tragic here they
don't have to have faith though so this
is something kind of new that Abraham
brings Abraham goes through the tragic
situation and then goes further and
notice the narrator in Kierkegaard's
book is not saying that he's a knight of
faith he's saying I I see this happen I
see the importance of this I can't do
the the movements of the infinity says
he says generally people are the opinion
that with faith produces not a work of
art that its course and common work only
for the more clumsy natures but in fact
this is far from the truth we often look
at religious people as if they're just
dummies that believe in things and they
don't you know they're not content to
seek things out to really think things
through we don't actually know that
that's the case as a matter of fact if
you look at religious people and you do
so it's sort of objective unbiased eyes
you often find out that they had to go
through a lot of searching before they
arrived at the position the conclusions
that they did so the dialectic of faith
is the finest and most remarkable of all
it possesses an elevation of which I can
indeed form a common conception but
nothing more I'm able to make from the
springboard the great leap whereby it
casts them to infinity I could walk
around existence on my head but the next
thing I cannot do for I can that form
the miraculous but only be astonished by
it
upon this pinnacle stand stands Abraham
the last sight he loses sight of the
last stage he was excited as the infant
in Asia he really goes further in riches
faith now your ticker is talking about
things that marked faith he says for all
these caricatures of faith the miserable
lukewarm indolence which thinks I
there's no instant need it's not worth
while sorrowing before the time the
pitiful hope which says one cannot know
what's going to happen if I possibly be
already after all these are part of
life's wretchedness life is over life is
hard and infinite resignation means
accepting the limitations of life
accepting that things are not going to
go your way
accepting that good does not always
triumph over evil that good people get
sick and die of terrible diseases a lot
of bad people go around and live a great
life that you only get what maybe 80
years you may have a few chances that
true happiness might have thrown some of
them away already well that's all part
of what he's calling infinite
resignation he says Abraham I cannot
understand in a certain sense there's
nothing I can learn from him but
astonishment if people answer it
fancy that considering the output of the
story they might let themselves be moved
to believe they deceive themselves and
wants a swindle God out of the first
movement of faith the infinite
resignation now this is really
interesting Kierkegaard is saying that
if you don't pass through that infinite
resignation you can't actually have
faith
so just believing in God because your
parents raised you to believe in God is
not what Kierkegaard would call having
faith it's looking at things looking at
life oh yeah this is this is
what people said it was converted this
is much worse you know this is null also
so great and then doing beyond them so
it's not this kind of Pollyanna
everything is great you know God loves
me and I love God that's saying that
sort of thing that's not what what
Kierkegaard calls faith it's not naivete
it's a sort of joy and Trust that comes
after passing through this this much
difficulty which that's kind of
interesting
so could good children for Kierkegaard
have faith what do you think we say
six-year-olds to the six-year-old they
do don't need six year olds from life
looked at life and said I've looked at a
lot of living and it doesn't seem so hot
and people don't measure up to my
expectations
you don't need six year olds let talk
like that could there be any I I don't
know I mean if there were they'd be
really jaded you have to pass through
for kick a guy you have to pass through
looking reality straight in the face and
seeing that it doesn't appear to be
magical wonderful put the fairy tales
away and then after that
he says the Knights of infinite
resignation are easily recognized their
gait is gliding and assured I mean if
you can come to terms with that that
makes you very tough good yeah so after
all this he believes in God does that
what he's kind of like getting to who
knows who's saying they may not be for
some people but for him yeah
Kierkegaard had his own trials part of
his biography is that when he had to
debate about a couple of things he had a
father that he had a very stormy
relationship he also had a fiance that
he gave up and sort of drove away in
order that he could pursue what he felt
to be his vocation as a writer imagine
that you know somebody who you're in
love with loves you and you push them
away because you're feeling or thinking
that God has selected you for something
different that would be very tough not
only would it be tough to do when that
hurt deep inside
let's yeah let's gonna see I thought
let's move on to something that because
they you know this is a design this is
something that I do have on the exam so
I sort of a duty to make sure that you
guys are introduced to it he talks about
what Abraham is doing with this sort of
technical terminology so so far we've
you know nights that he talks about
suspension what do we use that term you
talked about this last class somebody's
ethical what do they do the right thing
okay so what does the right thing
usually look like and you can use any
moral theory than what is doing the
right thing or think about your own
experience when you've done the right
thing that's been hard for you to do
what that look like why is it hard
think about like trivial trivial
examples you're all pretty well-behaved
I'm guessing there was a time when you
worked here kids
maybe huh lock hit somebody or said
something really mean to them
maybe swore it then something like that
then you quit doing that after a while
even though you were still in situations
where you can't felt like doing that
this does ring true freedom other kids
were mean to you and what did you do
instead of hitting them how did you do
the right thing that could be at your
parents may have told you that have
somebody is you know bullying you don't
give them the satisfaction sometimes it
works it doesn't you you engage in a
project where you had to make a choice
and you chose instead of doing the easy
thing instead of doing what you felt
like doing you did something different
right you identify to something bigger
than yourself how many of you have
babysat what's that like when you get
money out of it hopefully
just where use this free labor by your
parents what's it like taking care of
your kids suddenly you're responsible
right yeah you know kids are annoying
aren't they sometimes sometimes you'd
like to like put them in the closet so
you don't come out but you don't do that
right why not
kids say oh they put me in the closet
that's not why you did it right you you
didn't do the wrong thing you sacrifice
something your immediate impulse you put
up with something
now think about bigger sacrifices doing
the right thing often involves paying
attention to does a firefighter do the
right thing when they rush into the
burning building they're doing a crazy
thing they're going into a burning
building where they could get hit and
hurt a lot some of them died okay why do
they do that why why do we look up to
them as good people because we like
crazy people do you know Filardi things
yeah you're willing to let risk their
lives and even like their kids growing
up without a dad or a mom or you know
spouses being separated for complete
strangers you're right because those
strangers are members of a community
your community can be really small could
just be your family but it could be as
wide as the entire world walk for all
human height and to do the ethical thing
is to identify with what he calls the
universe to make the universal more
important than the particular so I'm a
particular the Maris community is the
universal so instead of just
indulging in my desires or let's think
about this the thing about the class the
people that we studied this semester
they are among the people that I like to
teach the most but I had to leave some
people out that I would have preferred
to teach why did I do that what do you
think why should the class be structured
the way it is
should it be structured just to you know
I get to teach whatever I like to yeah
you should learn the basics right the
class is not about me the plan of our
own pocket our class is about you and
your learning and you walking away from
here having been introduced to some of
the most important minds of philosophy I
would love to have to spend the whole
semester talking about blazed Pascual
but I don't do that because he's not
that important in the history of
philosophy or I could spend the whole
semester is doing Kierkegaard I really I
really enjoyed you but we shouldn't do
that because you guys need to be exposed
to a whole array of thinkers classic
thinkers the thinkers that other people
are not me
other people think are the most
important ones for growing minds to come
in contact well that's identified with
the universal over the particular all
right what is Abraham doing
see you can you can have all the levels
of the ethical like you could say well
my family is not as important as the
town I will sacrifice the needs of my
family because there's a bigger picture
thing here the state that would be
ethical that would be the right thing to
do in some cases what is Abraham from an
ethical standpoint he's committing
murder
and he doesn't actually do it but he's
ready to do it isn't he is there any way
you can kind of spin that I mean you
could you can do some murders maybe that
would be ethical like if you went back
in time for murder Hitler would that be
a good thing
it'd be a lot better than it'd be bad
wouldn't it cuz he's gonna win you've
led to kill people yeah what would
Socrates say Yeah right
you're right Socrates would would say
it's doing it's doing harm I guess I'm
more of a utilitarian whatever I can see
this and I think that Kierkegaard might
actually in some respects when it comes
to the athlete will be willing to say
you know if you if you've got somebody
who's like a you know a terrible person
you'll notice that killing them who
saves all the other people that would be
the ethical thing to do but Abraham's
not doing anything I'm busy there's no
greater community that he's gonna serve
by by killing Isaac as a matter of fact
what he's doing in any part according to
the ethical is wrong so why is he doing
it yeah that's that so yeah God is
greater is a greater concern than
anything that's applicable so when he
started with Killian logical this means
higher and something that
here's another term that he uses in
commencer when you say this whole thing
is in commensurable that means that's a
fancy word for saying you can't compare
it with something else if there is a
duty to God that Duty trumps everything
else so that that's a big one right
there I mean that doesn't necessarily
mean there is a duty to God but if there
is a God and you have duties towards
that God according to Kierkegaard those
duties would trump any sort of ethical
duties that you have so they would
suspend the ethical does that mean the
ethical doesn't matter them no because
you know if it's only in that case
Abraham is the story of Abraham we all
ought to go out and sacrifice our kids
because God likes that you know well
you're actually talking about that the
book this is you know if somebody were
to go to your sermon about Abraham and
they're to say this is great I'm going
home I'm gonna kill my kid now because
God likes that clearly Abraham's example
it's not saying that the ethical is
nullified is no longer the picture it's
just suspended in this case and it's
totally unpredictable
could could Abraham you know figure out
ahead of time which things can she
wasn't going to know so if again this is
why is here right if there is a God if
that God does impose demands oh like if
you know God talks to you tomorrow
it says there's Lois
who wouldn't save as well as write use
your first name but I want you to go do
this and sometimes you know the things
that people say God wants them to do
often you know really inscrutable you
know Peter gets told in one of the
stories you're supposed to go to this
guy's house by the way he's not a Jew
and going in there it's gonna be you
know probably polluting yourself going
to this house and do this and this and
this and really you I'm going to do that
that's the way that that those calls
would come you can't predict them can't
control them you can't just bring them
into the ethical this is kind of an
interesting philosophical position to
take because if it takes us beyond
philosophy just I think it's a really
good place to end the semester not
necessarily you know because anybody
believes or doesn't believe at this
point but because it shows us one of the
limits reason and so this is our last
class I hope you guys got a lot out of
this I've certainly got a lot of
discussing these things with you